it's the middle of the night
and we're in the eastern mountains along
lebanon's border with syria
there's no moon it's pitch black perfect
conditions
for smugglers and human traffickers
trying to move fuel
weapons and people between the two
countries
so the brighter light on the top of that
hill is a lebanese army outpost
the fainter lights behind are the syrian
army
and then the valleys in between which is
basically no man's land between the
lebanese border and the syrian border
they're some of the main smuggling
routes and that is why the focus is on
that particular part of the land
already tonight they've seized gallons
of diesel fuel is scarce and expensive
in lebanon
but it's even more so in syria
foreign
its first light down in the bakar valley
and attention now switches to the syrian
refugee camps
there are more than two million syrians
living in lebanon
most in awful conditions and they're
vulnerable to the gangs that run
much of this region the soldiers search
the tents for weapons
and islamic states sleeper cells if the
military collapses and lebanon falls
into conflict
this valley will be another route for
terrorists to reach europe
things are bad money's become so tight
that the army is now growing its own
vegetables and raising chickens for food
12 months ago a young soldier like this
would have earned 1300
a month today in this economic
depression it's just a hundred dollars
that is not enough to feed his family
senior commanders are now worried that
soldiers might be open to bribes from
local drug gangs
to turn a blind eye who would assert
that a saudi would be ready to be killed
in action
to offer his life for his country when
he knows that his family
is hungry and doesn't have
the basic needs to survive and live in
integrity
so this is those questions are really
worrying and we should take care about
it
and we should be aware that they could
happen
although we would not like but
it could happen if we don't have the
necessary support
and the adequate support in a timely
manner
what's timely
according to this tragic and rapid
devaluation of the lebanese pound and
the
iterating economic situation
two to three months maybe you never know
maybe less
in the last few days lebanese and syrian
migrants have been intercepted
trying to reach cyprus this problem is
getting worse
by the week the lebanese currency has
collapsed
and the government is in disarray if the
armed forces go
too lebanon could descend into complete
chaos
to be another failed state on europe's
borders
aleister bunkel sky news on the lebanese
syrian border